but the issue i get is when we start
letting people live in delusion there's
consequences and i really do on some
level think that it's delusional because
you're saying you're something you're
not
and and the problem is now we have leah
thomas coming in who's that leah thomas
the swimmer the swimmer okay and
swimming in the women's division
and taking away opportunities from women
like real biological women because in my
opinion we we started by letting them
live in delusion okay and and it slowly
got to the point that now actual real
women are losing opportunities in
athletics right okay
right that's what happens when you live
in that's what that's what happens when
you say oh but they feel a certain way
so we have to respect it genuinely it
has real world as much as i would love
to um
you know give a viewpoint on that i
can't
because
one i'm not trans i feel like i can't
speak on it until i speak to other trans
people who are athletes as well as
cisgender people who are athletes and
see how they feel about it and two i'm
still
curating my research on that because
i'll be honest
throughout high school i felt that way
yeah i was like why the hell are trans
people
ending up in
divisions that i feel like they're not
supposed to be i realized that so that
happened at your school
no
i realized that um
it was me
denying their identity in a sense right
um i know that realistically no matter
what this person was born opposite of
what they are but i do not want to i uh
deny how they feel
and what they've experienced since more
than likely such a young age
about what they identify as
but at the same time like i have to look
at the science behind this right like
because i've seen a lot of trans people
come out and say like listen my my body
has changed completely specifically with
women at least trans women
um they're like
i don't understand why people get so
upset about trans women entering women's
divisions because estrogen really does
break down our like muscle mass and like
our strength that we had as men
previously yeah bone density though
no
i'm sure but that's what i'm saying
that's why i'm saying like i have to do
more research on it first before i can
really curate an idea on it
um of like cheering with it because i
could understand like i used to feel
that way genuinely like i was like yo
i'm a girl and i i feel like i'm
fighting for my [ __ ] life and it's
already hard enough as a black girl at
that right like
we we have to deal with [ __ ] from
both racism and sexism yeah well i just
think it's like disrespectful to like to
honestly to when real women like women
that were born that way because we go
through [ __ ] they'll never go through
they will never go for a smear test
yeah nothing to understand like like
what what do we deem a real woman though
like i'm just curious what's a real
woman a woman that was born biologically
with a what is it a woman xy xx sorry xx
chromosome and a wound and i i know
they're gonna like bring out exceptions
to them
intersex people that's what they do yeah
but like
like or the the
few girls that have fertility issues but
that's very different than surgically
changing a dick into a vagina okay no i
i hear you i hear you
um
i think again like because i'm part of
the community yeah i have more insight
on how they feel about it yeah and i can
go off of that better as opposed to the
like i said this isn't how you feel not
done talking i know you know but i'm
just letting you know this no i don't
want to talk about how you feel when i'm
done
when i'm done speaking when i'm done
speaking listen why are you talking
about feelings we're talking about facts
you're gonna have to stop him before i
do
what are you gonna do
there's no listen
what are you what are you trying to do
nothing i'm just asking the question so
like so like it's a it's a we're all
talking right yeah but that's what i'm
saying we've been able to interact fine
yeah and you know if we cut each other
off we're like all right like gucci like
oh wait my bad like whatever i just
don't know right here just keep popping
like i just don't like anything
like you just don't like being cut off
by a man that's what it is like it is so
irritating you don't like being caught
up by a man no because you keep on
saying like oh facts over feelings facts
over feelings like no like at least when
pearl is interrupting me she's saying
like oh wait but
like this is this is what i see this is
what i know you're just saying no facts
over feelings
what if he puts butt facts over here
feelings
he could get [ __ ] slapped i just like
like do you know what i'm saying like
really like and i think what he's trying
to say is like their feelings about it
don't really matter
it's all about like but if we function
if we functioned off of only logic and
reality we would be a heartless society
genuinely i believe that
i don't know i think i think
carlos in second place
the girl that got second to leah thomas
would be cool right now okay so okay
for example just going based off of
their emotions sheer emotions yeah like
and not even in a not even close to
logical sense you can find a balance
between emotion and logic yeah you can
find a common ground i fully understand
anyway
we can find a balance between emotion
and logic i do believe that there are
times where we have too much logic and
too much emotion right
ah what do you think would you think
that was too much emotion or too much
logic i think it was me telling you to
shut the [ __ ] up because you don't know
how to sometimes
but anyway
i said what i said all right no i hate
you i had you i had you to go hand in
hand in times like this when there's too
much emotion involved people can
genuinely get hurt
and when it comes to logic i feel like
logic most of the time you can't go
wrong but sometimes when we're too
logical it can really disregard a group
of people or whatever it may be you know
yeah but that's that but that's one of
the problems i'm talking about we're not
talking about disregarding people
but that's not one
but
the fact that people um
actually think that speaking things that
make sense is disregarding people is
where we have a problem in the society
because if somebody is speaking to make
sense and you take it as oh you're
disregarding me no like i said i think
these people trans people deserve their
human rights i don't think of them as
less as a human being i'm saying when it
comes to things like you coming into ah
and when it comes don't speak when it
comes to you um going into a sports
arena that is not actually meant for you
and it's meant for biological women then
we see real world consequences to um
your feelings and people catering to
people's feelings that's what i'm saying
but
again i said that i cannot curate an
opinion on that until i do more research
i will not open my mouth on something
that i don't know
[ __ ] about
at the end of the day you know like that
that would just be dumb so but okay so
for you the main thing that you agree
with feminism on like the main rights
that women need to see today is abortion
bodily autonomy
because it's not always just you know
it's not it's not just abortion like in
some states or at least some counties
it's legal for
a police officer to assault an inmate
that's
while they're in custody right like so
let's say i were to be um arrested
and a cop could take me to whatever
little jail cell at whatever little
uh you know place for custody
he could sexually assault me legally
are you sure yes
okay i promise you can do some research
on it i have seen hang on you can
legally sexually assault somebody yes
a cop specifically like what are you
talk what are we classing a sexual
assault now that's what i'm trying to
understand so what what is this sexual
assault that this man can do legally
what is it that you can do grape
legally yes technically he can yeah in
some states it's like an outdated law
but it's still in place and it does
happen to people
i mean i'd love to see the research on
that i'm not gonna i'd love to see the
research on that do you have it i'm just
curious
i'll see if i can find it because i i've
just never that sounds like kind of
wild to me can i can i before we get
before we continue
just point out um chesca's female
privilege except when she threatened to
slap me did you think that do you think
that it would have been received well if
i threatened to slap her
yeah she's like because she would have
been laughing one more time
i was asking if it would have been
received the same way i'm just asking
that's it
right okay
just glad we just